-Good evening. I'm Seth Meyers.
This is "Late Night."
We hope
you're doing well tonight.
And now we're going to
get to the news.
President Biden said on Friday
that Russia would pay
"a severe price"
if they used
chemical weapons in Ukraine.
A severe price,
or as it's now known, "premium."
[ Laughter ]
President Biden spoke on Friday
with Ukrainian
President Volodymyr Zelenskyy
for nearly 50 minutes.
Zelenskyy asked for more
sanctions against Russia,
like maybe call Putin and keep
him on the phone for 50 minutes.
[ Laughter ]
The head of Russia's
National Guard said yesterday
that the invasion of Ukraine
has been slower than expected.
Oh, interesting. I wonder
what his replacement will say.
"Things are right on track!"
[ Laughter ]
President Biden on Friday
urged House Democrats
to talk up
the party's accomplishments
going into midterm elections.
Said Democrats, "Um,
we got Pelosi's lectern back?"
[ Laughter ]
United Airlines
announced last week
that employees
who were placed on unpaid leave
for refusing to get vaccinated
can return to work
later this month.
So don't worry, your pilot
might be unvaccinated,
but at least
he's also out of practice.
[ Laughter ]
A Florida man
was arrested last week
after he allegedly
called the police
and asked them to test
the crystal meth he'd purchased
to ensure it was authentic.
[ Laughter ]
Said the man,
"So is that a yes?"
[ Laughter ]
[ Chuckles ]
"I get one phone call?
I got great news, Scootch!"
[ Laughter ]
During a recent episode
of the competition show
"The Masked Singer,"
a contestant accidentally
knocked their mask off.
Luckily, since it was
"The Masked Singer,"
the judges
still didn't know who it was.
[ Laughter ]
"Oh, the guy from the thing."
Actor Jussie Smollett
was sentenced to five months
in a Chicago jail last week
for staging a hate crime.
Here's what you do, Jussie.
First day in the joint, walk up
to the biggest guy in there
and say, "Act like
you're beating me up."
[ Laughter ]
"It never doesn't work."
According to a new poll,
Seattle is the most desirable
post-graduation city
for college students.
That story again -- Gen Z just
discovered "Frasier" on Peacock.
[ Laughter ]
That story, again --
Karen, our writer Karen,
just discovered "Frasier."
[ Laughter ]
And finally, a man in Florida --
by the way, I had to
separate our Florida jokes.
[ Laughter ]
We're just going to act
like this is the first one
when we all remember the crystal
meth guy a few jokes back.
[ Laughter ]
[ Chuckles ]
That guy went first.
When we ordered them,
we were like,
"That one, I think
we can put him early."
And finally, a man in Florida
was arrested last week
after he was
allegedly caught masturbating
in a Miami Beach Starbucks.
Employees suspected
the man was unhinged
the moment he ordered a
Starbucks breakfast sandwich.
[ Laughter ]
In the end,
it was a joke about Starbucks.
[ Laughter ]
And that was the monologue,
everybody!